you look at live pictures now of the
school in parkland Florida that's
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School and
that is the FBI at work it's still a
crime scene of course and we've just had
confirmation as if you're just tuning in
that apparently the bodies remain inside
the school unfortunately George Nesmith
is the student at stomach Douglas High
School he knew the shooter and he joins
us tonight thanks for joining us so you
Nicholas Cruz was your impression can
you give us an example he he music was
expelled from high school we've been
told do you know why he was expelled
with it with without violating the
privacy of anyone necessarily but what
was his family situation like when you
saw his name this afternoon and connect
with this mass shooting what was your
first response I didn't really know how
to react
I knew that [ __ ] was bad but I didn't he
was bad right well it sounds like nobody
did but you weren't totally shocked then
I mean I just shot shot
yeah well it's shocking for sure George
cesspit thanks a lot for coming on
tonight
give these that perspective